[Music]
yo it's me what's up welcome back to the
podcast
I am tired guys I just got back from
surf camp down in Coronado San Diego the
whole family
we went down to surf camp which I never
really was privy to before I had kids I
wasn't wasn't a boy scout didn't do in
these scouting activities but my son is
and so one of the activities they plan
every year is surf camp you go down to
San Diego Coronado and you're on the
beach and ya get a tent and you set up
the tents and the kids play and then you
know they make food for you which is
great so you're not to do any of that
stuff but it was pretty cool we went on
a tent camping family we're a hotel
family so this is very new to us
so we got out bought a tent and some
sleeping bags and went down on Friday
night and set everything up and it was a
blast I mean they had archery and
rock-climbing and surfing all these
different activities for the kids the
parents just got to hang out and you
know we got to partake in some of them
and and then at night it was just you
know bonfires and and you know s'mores
and the kids just literally ran and
played on the beach too like 10:30 at
night and then everyone just goes
the tension goes to sleep now granted
you're sleeping on the floor I thought
I'd be sleeping on sand would be nice
and soft dude my hips are wrecked I
definitely do not need to hit the foam
roller this week because I've rolled it
out all over the sand I mean I'm just
turning and then my wife didn't bring
pillows like how do you forget the
pillows what are we supposed to put our
heads down on my kid like the kids are
one thing they need to sleep anywhere on
the floor doesn't matter no pillow
pillow I need a pillow all right I'm 40
years old I'm an old man needs a pillow
so I use my backpack as a pillow but
look other than getting a couple less
hours sleep than normal we really did
have an awesome time I would not I mean
then something I would do on my own
I've camped a couple times with some
friends but and usually it was just you
know heavy drinking and things like that
but this was like just a blast to be
able to be a new retired at the end of
the night you just said your shot the
kids give it up all day kids are running
around running you crazy so we really
did have a really good time and I can't
wait to go back next year I'm watching
the Yankee game right now I'm doing this
on Sunday night a lot of stuff to do
tomorrow but Yankees and the Red Sox are
playing at 0-0 and they split this
weekend series which so far the the
Yankees lost Game one on Friday and lost
on Saturday so this Red Sox series is
huge this I love baseball's getting just
really really good now this is the month
that things start tightening up
congratulations also adjusting Thomas on
your first career major victory in
engulfed I watched that this afternoon
he held off hideki Matsuyama and I
played really well this weekend I
thought Kevin kids knee was going to
take it you know he had a really steady
Eddy weekend I mean Thursday Friday and
then one over yesterday and kind of give
a couple back today so but Justin Thomas
I mean the guys
like probably 145 pounds and hits the
ball mile and super nice dude I was
happy to see Ricky Fowler and Jordan
speeds out they're congratulating him
when he got off 18 so that's awesome
I'm happy I'm going to play golf a
really nice place tomorrow Spanish Hills
in LA at a sentry containers celebrity
golf outing so I'm looking forward to
that tomorrow and then I'm heading to
Huntsville guys this weekend Huntsville
Alabama come on down will you please
I'm excited about this I've been Alabama
so Wednesday night going down there I
got shows Thursday Friday and Saturday
with my friend Jessica Michelle
singleton who will be opening for me
so we'll be heading down there this
weekend come on out and speaking of this
week this week's guest on the podcast is
one of my best buds Ryan O'Neal you know
him from the Danish Anil podcast Ryan
has is a writer and an actor producer
director him and Jeff or writing
partners and we've written stuff
together for years we did a series
called daddy knows best a couple years
back if you haven't checked it out it's
a it's a fun little web series check it
out on YouTube we did two seasons of
that we also did this little thing
called knockers that's on Facebook we
talked a little about that in the
podcast and so uh he's just one of the
funniest people I know he's got such a
crazy sort of upbringing in Valparaiso
Indiana and he's just a good dude funny
man we talked about the book fatal
vision and I don't have the author's
name in front of me I think McGinnis or
something like that and it's crazy it
was a true story sort of before there
was making a murderer there were these
murder crime novels and this is one of
them based on a true story about I think
this 1970s this guy this like green
beret
sort of medical doctor lived in Fort
Hood and family gets murdered and you
know all eyes go towards him and
it's just nuts it was a you know look
Ryan it's not a big reader so this was a
lot for him to you know he listened to
the audiobook and kind of we just kind
of chatted about you know these cases
and the flaws and the things the
mistakes that the cops make and you know
people mess up so the book is called
fatal vision and this is my good buddy
Ryan O'Neal enjoy I don't know what
you're talking about I was camping I
slept in a tent
okay what's the tent provided for you
know I bought the tent here's how the
tent provides out in San Diego
no I bought it when we were in New York
okay we told my brother-in-law but well
there you go
are you with my favors I feel very you
said I did not feel like I've attacted
you yes because you said I didn't camp
but I certainly did camp okay
what you woke up was there a meal
provided for you breakfast
whether they're also dinner provided and
lunch or you a in a mess hall do you
have your voice of what you could eat
now there was a mess hall set up yeah
like a bit yet I had like picnic tables
and stuff like that so the only thing
you had to bring was your own tent our
own Ken how far leaking bags how many
people were there there were about like
a hundred Boy Scouts and then like you
know coupled like the parents and stuff
like that is it this is a cake I had to
set up my own tent which I bought for my
brother-in-law he went near the Eagle
Scout so he went online to do Ted this
was he handed me a cart filled with
stuff that was almost forty four hundred
dollars and I was like what are you
doing he's like all right I can go yep
so this isn't like you didn't have to
like kill a buffalo
that skit it and then tan the hides and
then make your tents out of it no it
wasn't like right naked and afraid it
was two poles yeah
one goes this way the other one was
crossed and it just pops up yeah
everyone else put that mitt that thing
on the bit like that car over hop I
didn't put that on did you have one I
had one but I didn't put it on I was
like it's hot as hell with that thing on
dude
once that Sun comes up your [__] you
gotta get out of the tent but we had we
were on the beach like literally on the
water so there was in Coronado so there
was no it was a guy you know the marine
layer to like 11:00 a.m. so what we had
to worry about was like a little bit of
rain a little like mist while we were
having breakfast I had to run back and
throw that little top part on cuz I went
oh you don't read it there like sir
don't worry we'll keep your eggs or
we'll put about of this heat lamp here
so your definition of camping is
providing your own food is what is that
that's solely what are you have to like
bring it cook it prepare it do you know
I mean everyone that we were with did
say they were like you know like it's
great that we don't have to do food and
stuff like that or like clean and all
that stuff after it or it carry our ted
from our car they have people know I
carried it nice yep we had a flippin
bags I we blew it out we bought like one
of those beach carts so he'd just throw
everything on that sleeping bags how
many feet from your car were you
quarter-mile did I would said if you
walk it yeah I what yeah I walked it
twice no like we got there Friday then
we went to dinner Friday night we went
out all right Ron liked it like everyone
does when they go kay I think they can
set up there Ted
we said that by tent they have
reservations at a restaurant and we
didn't have reservations we had we just
walked into the whale I'm know we had to
wait like 20 minutes we got that was
very frustrating that is probably the
roughest part of campus is was waiting
on our reservation a restaurant and then
you have to sit there and wait dude we
got to go camping sometime where do you
want to go I think the whoop
why would just walk got to show you my
tent after it's really nice how many
Peters like a poor person really yeah
does everyone have their own like
private room with their own bath no it's
just one big square oh where their
outhouses and everything Lee is a
hoarder potty and then like if you want
to walk like the X with a nice porta
potty though this
to potty was I mean like look it had a
little side piss area the dumper and
then like a man sink thing but I mean
after the first two hours it was
terrible
well you are canned rather like you know
200 300 feet then you got to like where
the bathrooms where where the showers
are and stuff like that let's take a
shower yesterday what you don't shower
when you can't pony when you just take
up the whole [__] would do some days
I don't shower what I'm at home exactly
though sometimes you know why though
what - that's under planning a oh now is
over cleanliness may be a contributor to
Alzheimer's man I believe that because
you you were the first person to tell me
not to wear deodorant and that I've
wearing it no I still wear it
I wear the extra eye were extra doing
right now I want to go so I want
Alzheimer's bring it on ASAP you want to
forget your memories already pretty shot
it's pretty terrible although and second
my memory is fine are we back yeah we're
back my memories to remember to turn it
on wait let me look at it yes it's
alright okay
ah well it's a little little blurry at
times but yeah I messed it up a little
bit yeah I believe it was a car accident
I got into it in junior year is this the
one that rolled over on the railroad
tracks didn't roll over it just we
flipped over not on railroad tracks we
got hit and then we flipped over twice
and then God knows you blame it on
that's what I think it was man it just
hit like four years ago
and then like Tonetta really yeah when I
started like a little more pot stuff and
it got a little worse it's probably just
as bad as any other 40 year old man's I
take I don't know I take all the Rogan
stuff it's coming back you know but you
if you didn't smoke so much weed you
probably wouldn't need any of that stuff
I'm sure you wouldn't and you and you
want to be hanging around me remembering
everything no thanks I mean my mind like
a steel trap still yeah right it except
for the occasional when I go shrooming
with Ari I was a little bit then you go
up the way only once a year
yeah yeah what are you ever going those
trips I
which one's the camping ones yeah
well first of all those consider camping
yes why consider cam right why those
consider camping you don't bring your
own lights of your hair is that genell
which is net I'm naturally blonde in the
summer because uh I'm outside a lot yeah
you got rid of the red I don't get rid
of it just the Sun hits it the Sun hits
my hair it's lit up in the summer
natural highlight yeah and a lot of us
getting gray - where's this o'neill rose
to fame is it thought yeah
this is an inquisition no no I mean I go
on those chair I would go on those trips
aren't I do the ones like we you know we
do the ski one yeah and then we're going
to go down to Peru and do ayahuasca but
that's just to hit the reset button on
our lives yeah then he's talked about
after that yeah everything changes after
that our meal the Hiawatha yeah it's a
reset button it kind of cleanses
everything dude you're going to be one
of those guys that well one of the
people that is of getting raped by the
shaman now mark that's what's going to
happen well I mean our movies what all
dudes and they'll be like there's no
women on this trip looks like we're
gonna have two rapes or they go for
women right away they look at are his
[__] view oh no no next I've seen
that and that's what that's hopefully
what I can get during ayahuasca that way
my biggest fear is doing ayahuasca and
then like just like starting to go into
it and then like re bends over to pick
something up and like I see Hansel I was
like and then now boom my trip dude it's
all based on like going in and out of
Ari's [__] some shaman that lives in
the jungles he's always [__] that
looks like a meat grinder for dick it
was just really like shirting it he's
like I'm sneaking away from that thing I
don't like to make a larger like the
grinders put like the meat into the
sausage yeah and if its first three
turns of the grinder what comes out yeah
the [__] more like play-doh like ass
jam it through that thing oh yeah Harley
yeah but Dad we're going to go do maybe
i well we say we're going to do it he
wants to do it for like two weeks or go
down for two weeks physically to two
weeks what do you need you to uh we need
to get acclimated to the area I was like
you go you take the week I'll get there
a couple days early dude that's my
scariest thing I think it would be in
that jungle with all this I wouldn't be
sorting anything you go to the jungle to
do it I fly in I get to the hotel
ya-ya-ya-ya-ya my go where's the
ayahuasca uber uber to ayahuasca I hit
that real quick hit the reset button
come back and then that's good that's
good looking you know I think they like
- maybe like 10 miles into the jungle
what well I get you could do it probably
a number of different ways I told you
the way I want to do it you could
probably just have a shaman come to your
house and you could do Hiawatha in your
backyard no that doesn't count I want to
get out of town for a little bit Emile
yeah well why don't you just go over to
Azusa or something it's just a town over
already meet me in a air B&B where did
Airbnb been breakfast and azouz like
what are you doing what what is this
this is a I wanted to drop her oh well
I'll be interested to see how that is
those camping trips you guys do though
you guys make your own food uh well we
bought a p2 the last year [__] you okay
we did cook that night but we also
didn't go to bed so I did set up my tent
but I slept in a tent with Ari at
Bonnaroo and it was way more calm like
this tent the first night in surf camp
yeah I thought on the sand would be nice
and gets hard when you're in probably
hot like also have it completing the a
lot didn't do any of that
you didn't bring like a yoga mat or
anything to sleep on we brought we
bought these like $40 pads I bought four
of them okay they were like I don't
remember the name of them but like
they're like they look like the thing
you'd put in the front of your car so
that the reflector doesn't yeah so you
lay those down then we had sleeping bags
and Tracy forgot pillows ah what do you
have a beach now first time I used like
I went in there I had no pillows look at
the ground I just started ripping stuff
out of a bag and used took like her
clothes use of beach towel because the
beach towels were all wet they were
outside all man then the second night I
use my backpack right over here look at
this backpack O'Neill lethargy fit
you're like a young Bear Grylls right
now look at this look how many
compartments this thing has you fell in
love with everything yep let's see
what's randomly and one of these can par
what model it what is that is that a
detachable fanny pack that turn into
anything this is um this is a drug
this is the drug compartment what are
these diet pill I didn't want to bring
what hot so I just brought gummies a
gummies can't hang around kids O'Neill
did you know that and cannabis oil
gelatin capsules yeah those were in here
what the [__]
and then my wireless headphones and he
talks in case I get and then my clothes
I packed them all in here oh my god dude
this is a legit this thing even has one
of those uh water spigot pipes thing do
those are the worst they're so hard to
clean the camel valo as you can see look
all Proficient yuh ii did not enjoy
sleeping on the ground because after I
slept those 9 bays in Denver on the
floor thought about you I fell in love
with it you did yeah I've been trying to
get my fiancee to get rid of the bed and
sleep on the floor with just a thin pad
toss out the mattress in your carpet
no hardwood floors oh my god get a mat
thin mat that's what we had it did not
help my hips were like yeah you got it
you've got to build up we've got a real
dialysis from your hips in order to
survive it because then we went like we
had archery yesterday and surfing did
you how was your archery I just did some
archery in Tahoe uh I sliced my arm
yeah dude look at front right he's are
you supposed to do that one like you let
go it hit my forearm on my every time
well at every time like why usually yeah
three times you know I they actually
sell like a leather guard for your
forearm I was shooting PVC pipe like
with tips at the end of it that's what
this thing was until like hey sex
Jackson my son yeah he turned around
with like the thing pointing at people
there ladies off stop stop and she's
like helping him how she's like he's
like he's like guys this work I got it
and she's like no this we had to do and
he just look good she's like alright put
your arm out straight and do this and do
that he's a kind also he's just like
little lines it up and then rips a
bull's extrao it was like well that was
the best first shot ever in city to drop
it I'd be like hey I'm [__] Amish Way
is a which ways to mount the rock wall I
want to just run up to the top of that
thing real quick we did my brother used
to bow hunt
we're here killed it yeah you'd shoot
what do you aim for a yam like right
between a right behind the shoulder so
you don't aim for his dick with a German
and nuts first to slow them down
I'd so important topic right away yeah
well the dick has to be out so you've
got to do uh a major you gotta try to
get it hard wait for that little
lipstick to come out and then boom you
got to play audio of dear porn in order
to get a dick out and then you shoot the
tip of it and then hopefully the tip
will stick through a tree to run away
then you go up you slice its throat
we're gonna [__] hug how many people
have this is common knowledge yeah yeah
of course no dude I mean it hunting's a
pain in the ass like then you want to
kill it you got to do it and cut it open
take all its innards I don't like my I
don't like getting my hands dirty
what if you're having a seven day
hunting trip and the first day you kill
something you like you have to love
letting around with you for the rest of
the week no then you just get all the
meat off of it and then then what I cook
it or pack it up or dry it salt it turn
into some jerky yeah I know but I mean
you have seven more days like you done
after that or no then you just keep
killing dude you just keep killing what
do you skilful fine after that you like
well I got my offer fun
do you have you ever killed like uh I
might let me let me pause this for
second to make sure kitchen lawyer
without notice killed an animal is about
six one two two ever killed any uh human
animals now nope you never like even
kill to eat uh well I mean we yeah we
actually did I mean we fly our own
cattle and we never went to the store to
buy me we always had our own cows and
everything growing up you had your own
cow we had we had I got we have about
120 a head of cattle that we would
unform care yeah in Indiana yeah and we
had a lot of we had a lot of the Atrix
was that far 825 and the hotel was on
the farm no the hotel was in town oh it
was a real cosmopolitan of Motel Motel
sorry I did not want to class it up I
know you're real real strict about your
brand
there's a big difference hotel-motel so
your family grew up on a farm outside of
Indianapolis an 800 something acre farm
but then in town you had the motel that
you had my grandparents lived on the
farm they've eventually moved on the
grandparents bought the farm in like the
60s mm-hmm and then they had a Holiday
Inn across the street from our motel
that my grandfather my dad owned and
then we had our motel that we lived in
why that was a crime we had a trailer so
let's get a room that's a regular room
there's like a little apartment attached
to it oh and then we put a trailer on
the back of it so this was like a mega
place it was pretty big so you put your
year when you add it on to the motel you
just attach a trailer to the back
extension so like there was the office
of the motel you open it up that's our
living room okay then my brother and I
had a room on the right then you go
through the kitchen then there's a I'm
sorry dining rooms right when you walk
in then the kitchen then the living room
then there were these sliding glass
doors and you open them up and there's a
whole nother trailer back there yeah but
you're still a trailer it's not like
you're in a whole other building okay
you know there's a lot of square footage
god that's amazing though but then who
went back to take care of that like the
cattle and stuff during the day I will
introduce armed hands yeah there were
people that were running it and then
finally they were so incompetent that we
just took over ourselves so that's the
problem it was like a 24-hour so we had
a business yeah all farm is like 24
hours a day so how many yeah how do you
think yeah I mean dude I used to get
woken up in the middle of night because
the cattle had broken out and I'd have
to [__] go out there and we'd have to
- dad would wake you up and say yeah I'm
gonna go get one time was like [__]
just pouring rain and the Thunder
something scared them and they busted
through the fence so they were all over
the highway and everywhere and so I'm
out there how old wrench oh I was in
high school but I mean we used to get
pulled out of school - pregnancy test
cattle - if you like but my dad wasn't a
guy who planned ahead so it would be
like that honey Ryan O'Neal Ryan O'Neal
please come to the principal's office
Ryan O'Neal
Sonne you gotta get in the car we gotta
go get make sure this thing is do not
the [__] up I think one of the most
embarrassing moments was my
when I was 16 and I got the family truck
as my vehicle but one day my dad
borrowed it without telling me he
brought it back in the morning so I
could drive it to school but he he built
this cage at the back to hold all these
sheep it said about 4 feet above the cab
and it had sheep [__] all over it hay
and in the middle of the night he built
these cages yeah so he would like Hall
it begins I call some sheep like that
night somewhere and then he brought like
a rocket if you didn't want to get his
nice truck dirty so we use mine so I had
to drive this [__] truck I look like
the biggest hillbilly there was just
sheep [__] hanging off the edges a
everywhere I think I got a lot of [__]
for that my dad owned well a limousine
service so one of the motors so
sometimes one time to drop me off at
college
our biggest car that we had to be able
to do was a hearse he had owned the
hearse so he shoved me and my friend
John calandria that was my roommate in
college he lived in me near me just
shoves our [__] into the back of the
hearse and then dropped us off pulled up
to the dorm unpacked like you know did
he did he have had a 20 minutes to
unpack your [__] you bring it and then
have that wheel thing that wheels out
comes right out and all your [__] on
that he would line it up because my
dad's not lifting it in me and John are
gonna make trips up in that and we made
him as fast as we could people like what
yup guys like it weeks later in like the
the meal halls people who I came in did
you think dropped off in a hearse you
had heard I have no idea what the [__]
you're talking about
get out of my face yeah I don't know I
mean it's pay I guess is weird with
parents vehicles and [__] like that I
mean now your dad also is not I mean I
had the pleasure of probably seeing him
one time drive past my house but uh I he
was not bright he wasn't like a
businessman per se what would you say
that was that his dream to become like a
mogul of he was an entrepreneur like she
had a lot of businesses he did he ran
that Holiday Inn and then attach that
with a bowling alley that he had then he
had a restaurant that in town was very
well known that he had a theater yeah
and actually so when I did this is not
happening
uh-huh my dad always talked about Cheech
and Chong they used to come to the
theater quite a bit always like I'm not
a move
Road nose like a yeah like a road gig
got it and so I I talked to Tommy Chong
cuz he was on the same we were shooting
the same day and I asked him about the
Bridgeview Theatre in Valparaiso Indiana
he's like I was just thinking about that
place yesterday really because I loved
that place he's like it was off easy had
the hotel right across the parking lot
you go to the theater there was a great
restaurant to eat at it was like it was
hey Tommy do you remember
1985 when two young men came in there
and raped you that would be my brother
man no I Brotherhood and good enough
rape I did all the rape people the
raping of the judges not at the theater
ah yeah so I was like holy [__] you and
your brother and your sister work there
yeah work at all your dad's family biz
oh yeah my brother and I would be we'd
have to sometimes we get woken up in the
morning and the winter has happened a
lot there'd be a broken water line go
you gotta go find it and fix it so we'd
be digging water and it's 20 degrees out
we'd be freezing really had we'd have to
replace water line do you split Hey dig
a hole here look for this and this or
was like hey something's wrong and now
just go by I can tell me what it's fixed
yeah hey there's a there's a water line
broken it's probably over there
somewhere
go find it oh my god and then he would
come out to check because he was doing
other stuff too yeah it was like a pain
looking back it was a pain in the ass
yeah juggle all of these things but it
did give you a lot of different skills
not only people skills
the alele useless until the apocalypse
go look for a hole in the ground that's
leaking water yeah we use dowsing over
on cattle and get him off the [__]
Road what do you do when you go find
those cattle by the way when you find
you got a hurt them back in go yeah it's
tough because once they get spooked I
mean they will run through anything so
are you not a horse right you're in a
car I'm on a four-wheeler okay I did
have a horse but I didn't like riding I
don't like anything to write anything
that has its own brain I did I've seen
too many so you don't do piggyback
centres that we zero pick left to ride
anything no I have its own brain I've
seen these things take off with people I
saw a horse bite
woman at Yankee Stadium like a pepper
blew up ahead the blight is on she just
walked in the wrong spot is where I
don't like it all right yeah man's get
you a jacket on but like like like you'd
have you mean if you feed them carrots
this thing's got some [__] mean
chompers on them man yeah no thanks but
you didn't have to do that you are a TV
or whatever yeah just getting them all
I'd be on HIV or we attack defense right
we had a truck called the watermelon
truck and it was just this big 4x4 that
we supply us no with and we would jump
it and we would like just off-road in it
and we've chased cattle with that I
don't used to chase a couple video told
me once before you chased uh correct me
if I'm wrong prisoners escaped from the
jail yeah there's two different
incidents well I guess there was a
prison close to where you yeah the
Westville correctional facility was uh
about a mile away
so if a prisoner escaped we didn't want
them to like break into my grandmother's
house so we would load up with shotguns
and we would go try to hunt them
ourselves our dream was to find somebody
hiding on our property this all sounds
very crazy you wouldn't rather would
actually hope when you me my brother and
our other buddy with your tactical gear
together you're like today's a day a
tactical gear we've had we always had
clear hearts a couple guns with us
because you never knew what you needed
to shoot something a lot of coyotes out
there and you're talking live ammo
you're not talking like tasers or
anything like no no yeah like what you
know what's we all had like we had an
area called the dump and that was where
we would like there's a bunch of old
vehicles and we would shoot them and you
know there was I went out to hunt for
the for the criminal like did you stay
together or did you split up no we
stayed together and someone would drive
so we'll be sitting in the back we check
all the creeks and ditches we drive
around the property line we'd cruise the
country roads that does sound pretty
amazing that when you think about it as
far as adventures go most adventures for
kids are like hey I found you know you
heard about this porno or whatever in
the woods or whatever dude oh you were
literally lower [__] killer plus the
motel showed porno at night so we had
like a box of like hundreds of pornos
when I actually just threw away wait a
minute you're like oh so you're part of
your job would be to change the tapes no
my dad which
but he would be like close your eyes
kids going to make sure the tape like
figures wide open
ah but visualize is s to all these porn
30s the six is going into the video I
just
we were just unload because I was back
in Indiana a couple weeks ago cleaning
out three storage lockers and I finally
had to toss all the pornos that he has
in one giant box but we found one of
them actually survived
I was just unloading the pod yesterday
and it looked like the I thought it was
the analyst and I was like oh what movie
is this the analyst now realized he made
a list
I was like oh I haven't seen that one oh
let me pop that in but it was within a
bunch of other videos and so they were
unmarked and my mom's like just throw it
away there's probably all pornos and I
was like well what if some of our whole
video she goes alright well you sit you
watch all of it using it see what's on
him do the curate all this bored and go
through the regular isn't one of us yeah
children during Christmas who of us
raising horses riding around like a
Beatle song like it's your whole
childhood memory between the ill I'm
like oh I remember this porno Oh
next tape that's us a Christmas Jesus
man yeah mom's like gotta be just a
saint to deal with all the [__] you guys
she is where you and your brother and
your sister are all remarkable people as
well I've met all of them it was weird
you know they're all like you know good
jobs and families yeah I mean it could
have gone way worse I'm not one of you
guys isn't like a serial killer or
training I think I'm the black sheep
obviously of the family yeah we have a
little in that bad I mean you're a
lunatic but you're not like yeah but I'm
still like there on the grid and you're
we're all like fairly intelligent I
think the thing that saved us did you
guys go to smart in school
oh no it's terrible student oh dude
night you I I just found some old report
cards that I had like uh that I would
change the letter grade on them they
were so bad you mom wanted to believe so
bad but I was getting good grades so you
get nowhere today they would I remember
they gave us our report card to bring
home we remember this what do they call
deficiencies or did what I do things I
would probably mid like mid semester oh
you were like
failing yes why don't ya maybe you
didn't get him I got him all the time so
I would have to rush home and I would
have to check the mail for like that one
week I knew that they were coming out I
was just [__] I was just living in
pure anxiety it was it like a subject or
just school you did not like your uh
nothing interests me in school yeah
there's one of those things we'll look
at your life in the outside world I mean
what the hell they going to teach you if
you're chaining what are your goals over
running a [__] hotel
I'm sorry Motel a 800 acre farm yeah you
know I'll show you a thing or two
yeah how cool is your is your book gonna
be when I'm in the middle of night or
walking around my dad screaming about
fixing a [__] pipe in the book ground
and getting cattle back into a fence oh
well that's I mean when we lived at the
motel - it was insane
like I mean cops would come in through
the Doo doos on America's Most Wanted
that was staying there when I came to
the hotel I know the dude that one of
the liner at murder there there was no
yeah I think you told me that there's
been an uh probably we counted them up
last Christmas I think is about six
people we found dead there now when that
happened was it like hey by the way
don't go he running your mouth at school
about all the dead people we find this
hotel my mom like that I like me talking
about hotels our family business it
stays within a family and please okay
the murders stay here they've heard most
feel drank themselves death there was a
guy he was when I'm sorry the suicides
stay here in the early 80s my brother
was letting our geese out in the morning
before he went to school and he found a
dude that was living in one of the
trailers and he we actually found out
later he had AIDS and he'd killed
himself an old car my brother found him
and he had run a hose and through the
window and my brother came in he's like
uh yeah I think some AG's bed and guys
number four then but it was at like this
is right when AIDS broke and so then my
mom was cleaning out the trailer she's
like you kids do not come in not know
how this read so she was wearing like a
hazmat oh man yeah God it was a I used
to eivin's last time I found one I was
probably I was in my mid-20s I think of
my mom's like
there's a guy saying his room I haven't
seen him in a few days if you go knock
on the door hayri right can I ask you
questions so I open it up the guy's just
laying on the bed like bloated in the
bed and I saw my mom is over there you
open the door you're like creak and then
like I'm like yup hello well as I'm over
here like hello sir hello hello and I go
well he's not responsive and then I die
I think he's dead that's what I told my
giver finding one chill jerkin it know
which would be the way that people would
go now it's like the number one way to
dine that would be we didn't have a lot
of closet space enough to like really
hang yourself
most guys do in the closet a hard bar
smart in the construction yeah well at
the time we we just had smaller rooms we
still it carpet on the wall I think it's
highly illegal now but we were
grandfathered at a wall yeah - like for
sound deadening really yeah it was
likely I guess yeah that would work
floor to wall carpeting god so once
before we sold it some guy had burned
down about a third of it um somebody
come to you must be I think he's
freebasing in there and then somebody
knocked on the door in the office and my
dad came out I was like one of the
mornings like hey I think your place is
on fire
there you go right get out you gonna go
put it all away this is what I like it
was like oh eight maybe oh man oh seven
and so he had to run he ran in to fill
up a bucket and that but then the smoke
got so bad he almost got trapped in
there so he got out is just like [__] it
let it burn with your parents pissed off
when you had bad grades is that why you
oh yeah because Lily had been honestly
how could they expect you to maintain
some sort of like normal school when
when all this craziness was hat like you
know
well they had higher education because
like we lived in a suburban house in a
cul-de-sac area it was like you know I
guess we none of us knew any diff you
know I mean we yeah like that was normal
so yeah you would have to get so we
didn't I didn't know I don't know what
like a different childhood would be like
like I can't like read to you before bed
and stuff Rinna ah my mom would yeah my
mom would but my mom was you know she
was super busy she was running the motel
add at the at the time before he's
running the farm was running multiple
businesses and restaurants and stuff so
and he was that he was like us he he was
out till like 3:00 in the morning every
night the key at a bar and he was closed
you know he had to close it down which
is good though because one night I cuz I
sleepwalk and I still do now like I have
these night terrors and I walked I was
probably like three or four probably
likes camping real fun with you right
well I I mean Abby like she I have these
full conversations with her where I can
question her head like I'm like a
[__] KGB interrogator in the middle
of them oh yeah it happens at least once
a week were you on Tuesday she I don't
lie to me are you
and she one times like maybe I should
[__] with him somehow but then she
decided not to and I was like you
probably should not because I don't know
but I have a knife that's on the
nightstand of course is that her knife
for you or not now I've given it to her
yeah a smart move readout okay I like to
be my wife one day
and I'd also like you to have this knife
one time I probably kill me one day as
well
once I before I met her I was with
somebody else and I swore Sam was in the
house and I ended up kicking the
bathroom door in because I thought there
was somebody in the bathroom you're like
that uh South African runner that kid
Oscar Pistorius oh yeah ever but you're
due to kill yourself
my nightmare is that I sleepwalk and
kill somebody you probably wrote it
yourself well hopefully you're
definitely not going to kill her she's
too smart she'll get out of the house
but you may end up murdering someone
else I unintentionally but you'll
definitely end up killing yourself I
can't have like guns near the head but
you do and that's the good part but you
do I I had you on the podcast because
number one I figured one of the funniest
people that I know but also your fans
are in session so Neil I'm telling you
every week I called a [__] loser a [__]
hey what's up [__] you won't have O'Neill
on the podcast look first of all that I
like I love old people well you're not
all the popular like six eight
I like I'm Annie you three yeah you got
Dana Sean why don't you have it O'Neill
on and I'm like why are you
first of all none of this makes any
sense and I don't why you're getting mad
at me I'm like I'm trying to have him on
you just can't read I just don't read
well is why I got bad grades in school
yeah I did not read well at all so uh
wow I I was in the audiobooks okay
that's an eye that counts to me
yeah what I and so I was originally
going to come in here and do a review of
it since the movies coming out and yeah
in September but so this audiobook for
it is 45 hours long it's a bit of a I am
28 hours into it now and it's getting
very repetitive and it's very hard to
push through you know like is it because
like yeah
28 hours 28 hours in I still have 17
hours to go
Oh which is like a whole other large
audio book but 45 hours it's insane so
then I decided I'm gonna let me do
something else so I listened to fatal
vision fatal vision it's a true-crime
book very popular it's about a crime
that happen in late 70s and that I
thought would be also right up your
alley it's about a guy who kills his
family what why would you think that
what's right up my alley I love my bus
you gotta go to I just went camping with
them O'Neal yeah I knew camping this guy
had it all charismatic guy this is the
70s yeah this is in the 70s okay it was
like true story is the true story yeah
this is like this book was like making a
murderer before decades before making a
murderer like this was like the case it
went on for like 10 years I'm trying to
get this guy arrested where'd it happen
it starts out in Fort Bragg and this guy
is a green beret physician he's 26 years
old he's like this good-looking muscular
dude he went to medical school at
Princeton sounds a lot like me it's like
you we get the right to this guy 27 just
just like me there's some other areas
super handsome there's diet pills that
play into this and stuff - oh really a
lot of vanity okay hold
I all right so then this guy ends up
while he's on the military base one
night
he calls the emergency service there and
says send somebody my family's just been
attacked by some hippies who were
screaming acid is groovy
killed the pigs and the operators like
will this happen on base and he's like
yeah she's like we have to call the MPS
so he just hangs up so some time passes
he finally calls the MPS they get there
and his wife has been clubbed and
stabbed to death he had two little girls
both of them clubbed and stabbed to
death as well him hit some minor
abrasions on his head claimed he had
been clubbed also but he also had some
puncture wounds on his body but they
were very strategically placed like it
and they didn't go that deep one was
just enough to like give him a minor
collapsed lung he claims that he had
that deep well he but it was like to the
point where you if I don't say had a
nice time ago I'm gonna go like a paper
cut O'Neill dude that's what they were
he was claiming you've been stabbed 26
times and beat with a club he had a
minor mark on his head like a minor
thing he claims that he had been not
they've been beating him with a club and
the blows he'd been defending himself
with his forearms no problems on his
arms meanwhile his wife had her arms
were broken in two places
ooh kid was broken one arm was broken in
two different places where they were
like trying to deflect the blow and he
claims that some chick and a floppy hat
and three dudes came in yelling acid his
groovy and killed the pigs absolute is
grooving and then in blood it was
written
kill the pigs in blood on the wall but
upon further examination somebody had
written it in blood wearing rubber
gloves
oh so this like a doctor rubber gloves
we don't know maybe this guy have like
bruises on him that like heat or like
marks on him that he was attacking
someone else like sometimes you know uh
you will yes so there were thing there
was a mark on his chest that looked like
a scratch or the MP's like what the [__]
like there's a video of this is it a 70
70 this is late 70s and so so there were
marks there's like a scratch what they
later determined with a scratch mark on
him mm-hmm and he also had he also told
the EMT he's like there's a knife if you
find my fingerprints on a knife it's
because I pulled it out of my wife's
chest what yeah he said that sir he said
this guy's arrogance and his hubris was
insane
so there are so many moving pieces to
this story but then also we'll find out
later that maybe somebody did do it
maybe it wasn't him yeah because why
would you write killed a pet like did he
have a Trinity was he unanswered himself
do they find drugs in the system now
well so also they lived in a tiny place
nothing was disturbed either were
created with his vampire digs there were
Christmas cards on the table that
weren't even knocked down they said if
there was that many people in this
[__] room waving clubs around
stabbing people the place would be
trashed nothing there was a table that
was overturned which they later put the
table back upright and knocked it over
themselves and it did it was like a
staged scene it landed on pot like laid
upside down it's not laying on its side
like it was so top-heavy that if you
knocked it over it would it would go up
all the way oh yeah the Christmas cards
were there there was a vase that was
knocked over been swinging would create
air that way yeah also if they had a
club they brought a club in there and
they tried to hit the ceiling very low
ceiling but at the time I like there was
articles about hippies like taking acid
you know you know they used to say
there's like satanic cults and [__] yeah
then it was there was never Anson yeah
there was never like any satanic cults
that were sacrificing people I mean I
gotta like razor blades and Halloween
candy yeah there was like never attire
for that old case yeah so but this guy
was like he was well-liked so is there a
trial now that they arrest him so he's
not at first he's not
suspect what yeah they're like because
he's this Green Beret physician okay
he's respected people on the fantail
them or people in the in the base like
him yep also weeks before he'd been
reading an article in like I don't know
Vanity Fair or something about people
taking acid and killing people he told
the police set no he told his buddy
weeks before he think you got to read
this article man this is crazy oh he had
in the article one of the quotes was
like kill the pigs one of these people
said oh man you know he did the research
and did it yeah but there's also up one
right kill the pigs on the wall also she
had been killed with an icepick he
claims it a no I own an icepick mmm-hmm
but people that have gone over the house
said yeah I used a nice pic all the time
of his house so I don't know what this
guy didn't get a lawyer during the
interrogation he's like I have nothing
to hide I'm gonna go in there he also he
was in the hospital forever and he just
kept talking about like what a horrific
thing it was how he had to fight all
these people didn't really talk about
the family a lot just kind of asked
about one of the girls here and they're
like it seems kind of weird he also
claimed he had all these injuries and
they looked at him they didn't even
[__] treat him other than the
collapsed lung
didn't stitch him up they didn't have to
do anything he claimed it and cut 26
times like fending off these knife
attacks in these clubs you'd hit by a
club you got a break abort yeah your
your arm or your you know a guy who was
literally bashed one of the little girls
heads end with one blow crushing her
skull you're gonna tell me that guy took
it easy on you yeah so um so then they
interrogate this guy and this is like
the most damning thing of all time so by
the way this book is narrated by
Christopher Reeves oh the audio book is
done as Christopher Reeve and also I
will just give a disclaimer this is the
abridged version yeah I was the only a
version that I know the audio book or
the woman version yeah it's really what
I could find so uh but Christopher Reeve
by the way amazing [__] nary yeah how
does that work by the way is it that
makes a difference I'm sure oh it does
man he was doing like also I forgot how
great of an actor he was because he was
he was doing the full interrogation they
read through it all and he was playing
this dude Jeffrey MacDonald is the guy's
name and he like was a totally different
character
it was great that's good so then they go
in they start asking this guy about and
there's this whole million holes in this
guy's story especially the ice pick he
claims he didn't have well here's the
problem all the evidence against this
guy was totally mishandled he was
wearing like pajama tops and [__] they
got thrown away there was no
fingerprints of any of the people the
guy we supposed to take fingerprints of
the little girls that he had gone to the
mortuary to have it done but he said
they look they'd already been prepped
you know for burial and the funeral
everything and he said that they look so
angelic I couldn't disturb him so he
didn't even take the [__]
fingerprints oh these are the people's
must work on the OJ trial - [__]
idiot dude his trash
somebody taken out the trash already I a
few things
EMTs had [__] with like they told not
to touch anything but because
specifically because military Pinellas
is just pure incompetence Wow dude the
things that happen for this guy like
what a lucky [__] it was like 50 [__]
issues like that a law you know a LOD
they law they didn't even have so if
you're him though do you have to bank on
on these people [__] up as well or do
you don't think he at all and I mean I
don't know it yet but yeah we don't know
yet but also all the issue did do it
he's been obviously hoping that all
these things are going to happen all
through the cracks I mean that seems
very by the way short-sighted to me
whoever killed one of them killed him in
a room and that put him in a sheet and
dragged them out into the living room
also they're from the club
there was fibers all over the Hat like
someone had been dragging this club
around like it's amazing the [__] that
they find like the blob was very [__]
club fibers I can't remember if they
found the is that only a bridge to
bridge every one of these I think in a
club even got thrown away like all this
[__] somehow got tossed and so they
basically only had circumstantial
evidence on this guy
they didn't have any they barely had any
evidence but
his account of what happened is the most
ridiculous [__] thing what'd he say
first of all he claims it was there was
four people in there a lady with a
floppy hat then two white guys and then
a black guy who was wearing a military
type uniform any black guy that's
militant the 70s is not hanging out with
two white dudes [__] I every chick yeah
and a hippie unless this is some like
weird gangbang scenario yeah doesn't
that none of this makes any sense that
those two guys are it was dark
he had been sleeping on the couch he did
fall asleep on the couch okay and he
blamed on is that he had woken up yeah
and these guys were standing over them
and they started clubbing him
and so but keep in mind lights are off
but he somehow was able to see this guy
was wearing a uniform it's supposed to
be pitch black how could you even tell
who was in there yeah then he claims
they clubbed him I think he got knocked
out then when he woke up he heard
screaming and like his wife had been
stabbed and clubbed to death two girls
have been stabbed and clubbed to death
but there's weird accounts cuz they take
any money did they take any no it was
just pure Oh sad well no just pure bad
acid trip is what he was claiming but
there's so much time between when all
this should had happened
that he's in there like he since he's a
physician he claims that he went into
like dr. Mowat trauma so he goes in to
check on the daughter but he goes in
there and claims that he tried to give
her mouth-to-mouth but there was blood
bubbling up whether she had been stabbed
like in her long long art turns out she
wasn't even stabbed in the lung hurt
really yeah and also he didn't say he
turned on the why is that
this is his excuse for like why my blood
and DNA or whatever probably meant DNA
but yeah but it's all over everyone but
also his hands were clean so he claims
that Don watch after before he called he
was washing his hands after examining
each [__] each [__] victim his wife
the kids because just what doctors do I
was in that mode oh man that he calls
the emergency claims has happened she
goes you have to call the MPS he doesn't
call the
he's for like two or three more minutes
you would think that that would be your
immediate I'm going right to the end yes
and this is why it would be very hard to
get away with anything because it's the
minutia that you would probably remember
if you were recounting an accurate story
but he forgot things like he didn't say
I ran into my daughter's room turned on
the light and checked on her so he
basically was saying that he was in
pitch-dark seeing blood bubbling up from
her lungs and examining her yeah review
this was a real story you'd probably
like I ran in there I couldn't [__]
see a thing
so I flipped on the light and there she
was yes and I wanna make sure no one
else was in the room to attack me I saw
that she was laying on the bed I ran
over there yeah those are the little
they ever get like what what would be
the benefit of him doing it like did it
what's did he was there a life insurance
policy to be gala fights with the wife
all the time no it's her and where the
kids not doing well in school
no claim to always gray and last one
would be real roughed kids [__] I know
so later we'll find out a possible
motivation he was also just a sociopath
okay like he it none of this should
bother them really like they said he was
like so unaffected by this it was insane
and so this examination just it starts
building like this just more like why
would you lie why would you say yeah I
own an ice pick they found it but so
then they finally these these
investigators that are on the military
base they bring it to a military trial
and the father-in-law you know of his
wife and this dude's on trial for murder
yes so they're like were charging him
there's enough [__] here that we
think we can get him with circumstantial
evidence but so the lady's father his
father-in-law loves this [__] guy he
goes if I had another daughter I would
want her to marry him like this guy
who's [__] hook line and sinker this
guy's the greatest guy in the world he
could never have done this so the guy
the trial goes on and there's not enough
evidence and he gets off work he gets
off they also find a girl who someone
had seen wearing a floppy hat who does
do a lot of acid who claims she can't
remember where she was they didn't know
where she was that night they found a
woman to go I wear
floppy hats I do a soul time and I
remember I was in marlin eleven she was
a drug informant and I and this guy's
like she's a very reliable person and
but they didn't charge her with a
because there was no evidence that she
was there but then this guy gets huge
notoriety he goes on late-night phone
Sean McCain came it's holy cow I didn't
know I know he's a war hero I have no
idea that he'd murdered yeah so he gets
off and uh by the way he's just banging
chicks on the base while this trial is
going on what he's just banging all the
here talking about that too yeah there
was like they interviewed a chick and
she was like he was a very handsome and
had a great body and he was the most
exciting thing on the base dude he went
on a [__] do you see what a good body
will get you see what it's like just
having a little bit of discipline not
even whenever you want whenever you want
and committing to the gym you can murder
people and still [__] could get you can
get a wife get her pregnant have those
kids murdered all that whole community
and then still while you're on trial for
being murder a murderer [__] other check
long as you've got abs as long as you
got like a six-pack so hard so now
there's like a [__] celebrity he's
going on late he's recanted like
recounting all of the [__] do people
feel bad for this dude like oh I feel
bad this guy can't find the murderer he
does the OJ thing we're like we're gonna
find out did it but now his
father-in-law starting to get a little
suspicious he needs to keep his
father-in-law on his side like he
doesn't want this father-in-law but he
realizes nobody's looking for the real
killer and he wants like he also has not
read what the the interview with the
[__] the interrogation that his
son-in-law had gone through so finally
after a while he gets a full like
hundred page copy of everything and he
[__] scours this thing and that's
what he goes this mother [__] did it
and he turns on this guy he [__]
turns on this dude and he's like I'm
gonna [__] I'm bringing this guy down
wait but wasn't there a trial trial yeah
but he's like Charo
I got nothing but time man I'm gonna
[__] find a way to bring this guy
down the bubble jet trial can't get it
with new evidence though you can took
him 10 years but he bring the back trial
meanwhile in that amount of time he this
[__] psycho
Jeff Jeffrey MacDonald called the
father-in-law and tells him look me and
some of my Green Beret buddies track
down one of the killers and I don't want
to say too much but we don't have to
worry about him anymore he goes that he
assassinated this [__] guy with his
Green Beret buddies by the way he was a
physician grebe ray he was doing like
clerical work and yet he blows [__] yeah
other guys were like real war heroes and
like Oh Manuel Green Berets so he claims
that he was out there hunting these guys
down just to like bother ah I like him
now I'm on his side at bay so the
father-in-law starts like digging and he
gets these other cops involved these
other detectives and so they started
building a case take some ten [__]
years
dude this goes up to the Supreme Court
because yeah this goes all the way up
this goes through all the local in order
for the Supreme Court
our people probably bitching because
this guy's been tried already he's been
yeah he's also been on like late night
talk shows talking about the trauma that
he had been in he also had the biggest
piece of [__] eternity of all time what
the military police attorney no no he
got his own attorney oh okay yeah this
so this guy this guy was like a scumbag
just like him and this guy was he was
like I finally parted ways at one point
because he he got this guy an interview
with a magazine but then the guy
realized that maybe the lawyer had
profited off that and he didn't and he's
like I gave all this information now how
am I gonna [__] sell a book if this
article comes out and gives all the good
stuff away gifts over goods all the
murderers that way I can't keep that for
myself I'll just have to go out and
murder more people dupa people [__]
love this guy so now he's 35 years old
he's living in Long Beach this is in the
80s now he's got a $350,000 condo on the
beach he's got a Maserati which is a lot
on me bet you
he's got a [__] boat and he's living
the good life is he still docked hernán
up yeah he's still a [__] doctor in
Long Beach making a ton of cash and so
finally they bring this back to trial
like big do a grand jury they bring this
guy on you know grand jury they just
want to interrogate in front of these
but this guy this guy is [__] the
jury hated this guy so much
they said he was such a [__] [__]
it was all his whole everything was
about him and all the problems that had
happened and like how this had ruined
his life and it was never about like the
wife and the daughters or anything oh my
god so they finally go all right there's
enough [__] here to yeah do a trial and
so they go through this long trial and
he ends up getting convicted what he
ends up getting convicted I always in a
regular court yeah a regular jet like a
regular judge not military yeah but this
is all after like dude they literally go
so the lawyer says it's double jeopardy
then they say there's new evidence they
overturn that finally after they go
through like multiple appellate courts
and then it goes up the Supreme Court
then the guy says it violates his right
to a speedy trial since it's been ten
years
they say [__] that finally one court
over says he's right and it up and he
you can't try them then they go up to
the higher court and this is this is
going on for [__] years they want
this guy yeah so they finally they
finally arrest him and he's being held
at like a prison near Long Beach and his
all his buddies at the hospital for his
birthday they hire a [__] [__]
plane with a happy birthday side that
his they bought it to fly over the
[__] prison and they're all paying his
mortgage on his condo paying all his
docking fees on his yacht because
they're like he's gonna get out bad he's
good I never heard her everyone by the
way he's been [__] chicks non-stop
this whole horse he has he has all these
hot young girls like Don Johnson yeah he
also so then I think he gets out [__]
table like they somehow release him and
he goes and buy the condo another condo
up in Mammoth Mountain finds his young
hot girl gets engaged to her and
then because I think they got something
overturned and then he's out for like a
year and then and he's with this hot
chick and so he finally gets it he
finally gets put away for good
three can three consecutive life
sentences what they found them guilty
for three consecutive wife standing his
wife and his two daughters yeah finally
so while he's in jail he hooks up with
this with the author of this who
actually just died I mean no way he died
at three years ago John McGinnis is the
author Joe McGinnis sorry Joe McGinnis
is the author of this book I was hoping
that you're going to tell me like he was
in Mammoth just chilling out and all
sudden like the father-in-law showed up
and just killed him no no but the
father-in-law kept threatening like the
Justice Department they're like look
this is going to get taken care of one
way or another really because when he
was in that prison oh yeah that's what
happened the lawyer had negotiated that
until sentencing and all this had
happened to let him out on on bond on
bail and that's when he bought a place
in Mammoth and he's out for like a year
meanwhile his mother is like Oh his
mother is I think he was [__] his
mother I don't know because his mother
was around lived with him all the time
was always nearby uh all times she like
loved him and like he could she probably
knew he did it so you could do he do no
wrong in her eyes so uh so then he's
rotting in prison meanwhile he will he
wants to get a hold of Robert Redford
because he think he'd be a great guy to
play a a movie movie yeah what United
saw him play guy writing up screenplay
of his life story I love this guy and so
but this is where it gets weird that's
where the author's like this is where it
gets weird is it well so then meanwhile
throughout all this ten years they keep
going back to the girl with the floppy
hat who does a ton of acid and at one
point she confesses to killing those
people is wrong with people confesses
why as they also Rea that his lawyer was
strong-arming her but she was also just
nuts she at times she went on a [__]
talk show and admitting to killing all
these people that's what I'm saying like
what what yeah acids crazy I don't know
man got him killed people yeah she was
just strung out she
then end up dying shortly after she had
gone out and confessed on and so does
that make you believe like maybe
somewhere in the back of your mind it
could have been that crazy chick with
the [__] hat are you just like a
hundred percent the whole time maybe
waiting for justice to be served there
is there is that it's not it like making
a murderer you're like Oh Stephen Avery
probably didn't do it but this it cast
doubt and the other thing when they're
looking for motivation the author starts
talking about how this guy was he was
very vain and he had joined the boxing
club on base and he also was running a
weight loss program and he was getting
all these guys on diet pills and this
guy he was he lost an enormous amount of
weight in a very short amount of time
so they thought he may have been like
triple dosing in these diet pills and
some of if you take too many of these
diet pills uh-huh it would cite you
could get psychosis really yeah so what
he speculates might have happened was
he'd been taking all these for weeks on
end
taking these diet pills maybe starting
to lose his [__] mind
and his wife and he got in a fight and
he probably hit the wife and or and then
got a claw out and then reader and
stabbed her and then the girl and
realized what he'd done it's like I have
to cover this up I'm just gonna kill
everybody and stab myself uh-huh so part
of you is like either way that's not an
excuse for what happened you like oof
okay yeah kill that wife out of rage
I'm not what the [__] I'm not saying
that that's you know but the killed in a
little girl has to turn around and do
that but if you're the [__] up on any
imagined 1970s diet pills yeah it is
exact but instead of me in there are
class-action lawsuits you see all the
time yeah for all the offenders and it's
been fun
Tracy's mom was on Sensen for like
Knebel year the 90s yeah back then they
were just taking like narcotics I was it
there's just like cocaine yeah a smaller
version so he could have lost his mind
but I think what it was in my opinion I
think it was just a multiplier effect of
a dude who was a psycho anyway I think
and then he would put a
on drugs and he probably had a real bad
temper and he the
he claims he was like so in love with
his wife that's where the title of the
book comes from he's like she was the
greatest woman I ever met and yet he
called her at the end he said she was a
fatal vision oh my god
so you put a psycho in there who's
probably he was banging other chicks on
the on the base she was probably giving
him [__] about that
that's probably what a [__] this he's
already on edge because he probably
doesn't sleep he claimed it like life
was great he's been spending more time
than ever with the family meanwhile they
look and he was working like 12-hour
days and just applied for like another
shift at another hospital it was like 10
miles outside of town really yeah he was
just I mean the lies that he told was
just lie after lie it's if you listen to
it or read it it's very fascinating when
did they read it so many twists and
turns I listened to it on the way back
from Tahoe okay yeah it was the first
time you read it yeah I was I want to go
back and relive into it again uh-huh I
recommend listening to it I mean I'm not
a reader because I I can't grasp how
people get joy out of reading because
it's why I labor cuz I know yeah think
so yeah it's so labor intensive yeah
this is not enjoyable this is like
knocking on a [__] tightrope for it's
like a job eight hours a day yeah it's
like it's a chore yep so now I just do
audiobooks that's good you find it
better to comprehend I mean I still
drink
I listen what I'm gonna get or get
through it like you could oh well I will
I mean I'm 20 I'm so invested now yeah
but you're only halfway well yeah I'm
like two-thirds almost okay but I'll
finish it I will finish it but to do
that 45 hours to recap that's the same
dude I don't know going on how I'm good
and lutely I can't see the movie now
until I find out how the end is what
happened at the end of the movie where
we were kids growing up yeah uh John
Ritter and uh with Tim Curry I think was
in it yeah but you're sad about Tim
Curry you see you know you had that I
didn't know he had like a stroke oh
really yeah and he's like in a
wheelchair he you can't you can barely
talk i but he was a couple years ago I
thought he passed away what did he die
and don't look it up I think well I know
that he had had that he was great as it
but I the movie overall was like it was
pretty shitty yeah I mean it was it was
pretty boring I'm looking up at Tim
Curry still alive this is terrible that
we don't know this if we supposed to is
gonna know but I always feel bad if like
you're talking about someone who's dead
yeah I know that he's been off the
market for a while
well maybe be a ticket it's nope he's
alive did he have a stroke uh doesn't
say it's tough well you see a guy
especially like him because he was like
such a such a performer singing and the
dancers yeah all the [__] um thank you
for doing the podcast man yeah man well
thank you for having me ah you're one of
my favorites I was going to take notes
but I was like dude there's so many
twists and turns in this and then I get
lost when I'm reading yeah [__] notes
but it's definitely worthwhile and he's
name of it again fatal vision David
around first since for a long time okay
and uh I think they ended up doing
another follow-up work before he passed
away he went and visited the guy guy
they became friend is he still alive I
believe he is rotting away in jail yeah
they moved him like what I could a new
wife she's just oh she left him well
they were in gale wish to and she's like
all right I'm out of here I'm done
yeah she's I thought you two crazy
killer you're great crazy on the loose
ocular guide now I can't be around a
jailed up killer guy no thanks
but yeah this is like it's weird because
when I when I was listened to I was like
this is like making a murderer yes it's
the predecessor to it the book is called
fatal fatal vision vision I Joe McGinnis
Joe McGinnis but he wrote a bunch of
other [__] too it's true crime it's a
it's a fascinating let me see if
McDonald is uh cos dude is still Jeffrey
are McDonald let me see if he's still if
you're listening to this by the little
Ivies in 270 oh really
yeah if you're still listening to this
by the way you're remarkable but also
why do people usually keep actually no
idea O'Neal's got a great podcast some
of you are probably familiar with it
already with our other friend Jeff Dane
is called Danish you know Neil yes at
one point it was called boner City USA
gone through different that was well
that was absolutely different podcast
but still it's one of my favorites to do
you guys are lunatics you do have a
rabid fan base yeah it's it and I'm very
happy to hear you on this I think it's a
good it's a good show take a listen to
it with basil to come out comes out
every Monday morning Monday and yeah
it's part of the all things comedy
networker you know you're on there and I
watch the go to Facebook and go to
knockers oh yeah go check out the
Facebook page knocker just putting
knockers in facebook okay rocker
signatures TV otherwise you get the
first day will come up will be just a
picture of huge tits and bikini tops
just look for me and then and I'm
wearing a horrible goatee in two
earrings so once you see budget many of
us that look was pretty by the way your
hair is exactly how we want remember we
tried to get the lady to put highlights
and she forgot to bring the stuff yep
this is how we want we wanted like
frosted tips yeah I get more of a
douchebag but it's a really funny sort
of series that these two knuckleheads
Jeff and Ryan directed and I started so
check it out on Facebook check out their
podcast thank you buddy
oh yeah thanks and uh maybe one day when
I finish it all uh yeah in about three
years when you're done with the book it
on audiobook the 500th hour I was going
home for the first like seven will be
five hundred guests number twenty five
and number five hundred a little a good
time mark as to when you [__] finish
the book uh yeah this was fun man it's a
great idea for a show thanks I
appreciate it the book check it out and
I'll talk to you guys later bye
[Music]
how long will I fly separate myself
don't believe it's bad
[Music]
don't you know even never go back I got
a team that was a hilarious Ryan O'Neal
thank you very much to him for doing the
podcast and please to all his legions of
fans you happy now
you got it all right good now leave me
alone please stop yelling at me and
calling me names thank you
let's talk about stand up for a second
I've got some dates coming up not only
am I in Huntsville Alabama this weekend
September I'm going to stay in Los
Angeles and work on my material and then
October 5th 6th and 7th Portland Oregon
the helium comedy club October 5 6 7
come on out I love that city like that
club a lot good people over there and
the following weekend I'm in Winnipeg in
Canada oh say can you see Canada
Thursday Friday Saturday October 12 13th
and 14th Winnipeg rumours comedy club
yet some will freeze their asses off
together
November San Fran 2 3 & 4
coming to Cobbs all right I did that
weekend last year it was a big big
success so gonna do it again and then
the following weekend I'm in Bellevue
Washington at the Paul I live the Paula
I've been there many times and Reubens
always been wonderful to me and then
Chicago and another city to be added in
December so tickets are on my website
come see me live tell me how much you
enjoy the podcast tell MA tell me what
you don't like brytny about the podcast
hear me this book at gmail.com Steve
Rannazzisi comm at Steve Rannazzisi on
Instagram I love you guys I'll talk to
you next week
later
[Music]
let me but dangers they never came and
de on the other side take it on the
other side
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
and separating us
the town
[Music]
she's in my place
Canada on me
[Music]
meet only understand she don't take it
on
[Music]
hurry
but don't believe me
[Music]
[Applause]
please
[Music]
Oh
but
[Music]
Oh
don't be
[Music]
you